Hey there friends. By chance, are you
feeling just a little bit blue? Well,
I've got the PO trick to demonstrate it
for you.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO, sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
take you through five tricks that are
excellent for conveying sadness to your
audience. But before we dive in, I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Parer, Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video. And special thanks to the
non-b businessiness friend of the
channel, Pekka Becklanin. Thank you so
very much for supporting my channel, my
work, and my mission. So, one thing I
hear a lot about my poi dance work is
that it's very expressive. There's a lot
of emotions there. And as part of that,
I often get people asking me how to
convey this emotion or that emotion. And
I figured I would go ahead and start off
with that most intense emotion of all,
sadness. So, what poet tricks convey
sadness? Well, the short answer to that
is that pretty much all of them do if
you perform them right. It's actually a
really helpful exercise to try just
flowing out and pick an emotion to
express in the course of doing so.
Sometimes it's happiness, sometimes it's
sadness, but this is an exercise that
will help you get a lot more out of what
you're doing and recognize that there
isn't just one right answer for
conveying an emotion. But if you're just
starting out at this, I'm going to give
you the cliff notes for a few po moves
that are a little bit better at this
than others. Starting with
trick number one, pendulums.
So, this is going to be a very common
theme on this list. You're going to see
a lot of po tricks that don't involve a
lot of movement of the poi actually
passing over the hands, which to me
definitely reads as sadness. Now, your
mileage may vary on this one, but I
personally find that pendulums combined
with really heavy and laborious movement
really does a good job of reading as
sadness. Bonus points if you keep your
head cowed over and your movements
plative and submissive. Furthermore, I
don't think there's any one timing and
direction mode that does a better job of
this than others. I'm kind of partial to
doing it in together opposites or split
opposites just cuz I think it's more
interesting, but your mileage may vary.
And it must be said there's a lot of
room for experimentation and exploration
here. Trick number two, 1.5s.
Yeah, I know this one is kind of a cheat
because it does incorporate a pendulum
into it, but we also get to spin the poi
just a little bit. And I think the
contrast between these two things really
helps to sell that sorrow. You can do
your 1.5s as the traditional 1.5 beat
weave here. Again, keep your movements
very heavy and laborious. We can also go
with our butterfly 1.5s if we want to.
This can definitely have a very
plantitative effect of like we're crying
out to the world whenever we do the
version of it that takes the pendulum
back behind our heads like so. Again,
there's a lot of options here. And of
course, we can always play around with
different placements for the hands,
having them separate
or together. We can play with different
volumes as we're doing this. Opening up
or playing around with different levels,
taking it down or taking it back up. All
these work.
Trick number three, cork screws.
All right. So, finally, we have both of
the poi consistently moving. And again,
they're moving in such a way that we can
keep the poi heads consistently below
our hands, which to me still reads as
kind of plative and a little bit
sorrowful. Here, I personally think that
corkcrews are a great way to be able to
explore a stage but still maintain that
heavy feeling and keeping those poi
beneath our hands. Bonus points on this
one. If you can use that motion of the
corkcrew to really emphasize the pain of
sadness, to really emphasize the weight
of it, because as the po go down in the
corkcrew, we can go down with them. We
can travel around with it. We can really
make the weight of what we're
experiencing be felt. And of course, if
you want to get fancy with it, you can
do it as the DNA corkcrew where you have
that horizontal buzz saw that separates
the two halves. That can make that
descending or ascending part feel even a
little bit more laborious, taking an
even longer time to do, and that of
course can contribute to the vibe as
well. Trick number four, horizontal
isolations.
So yeah, once again I am cheating a
little bit by taking something that is
functionally a lot like another one of
the tricks on this list, namely the
corkcrew, and taking it just a little
bit farther. What makes horizontal
isolations really pop for this, of
course, is the way in which they seem to
labor against gravity itself as we
isolate them in space. Like so. Of
course, what really sells this is really
making it feel incredibly hard to keep
that horizontal isolation going and of
course to slow it down to a stop or to
pick it back up again, making it a
Cifian task in and of itself. I will say
one special bonus of this too is that
especially if you line it up right, you
can almost make it believable that that
horizontal isolation is like tears
falling from your eyes if you line up
the silhouette properly. Maybe I'm
reading too much into it, but I think it
reads
trick number five, crossers.
Yeah. So, this is a horse of a different
color, isn't it? So, the big thing that
I think makes this read as sadness is
this moment where we're kind of holding
ourselves as though we're trying to
comfort ourselves. Crossers are really
the only PO trick that I can think of
that accomplish this because the labor
involved in doing a straight jacket is
just so much that there's no way to not
make it look like a struggle and not in
a sad kind of way. So, crossers, good
place to start. So, a bonus to this is
if you start off with a different trick
and then you get into the crossers,
really, really selling that moment that
you're trying to desperately comfort
yourself. And then, of course, you can
pop out in any one of the other tricks
we have on this list as well. Also,
don't be afraid to move around, maybe
pace in place a little bit as though
you're contemplating some terrible
moments. You can even come out of it and
really really sell the moment. Cool. So,
I hope this was helpful and I hope it
helps you all in writing your own po
pieces and showing how you can express
yourself in the process. Would you like
to see me do more list videos like this
where I go over PO tricks that are
helpful for conveying specific emotions?
Leave me a comment down below and let me
know which emotion you'd like to see me
cover next. Please make sure to like,
comment, share, and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my FL patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. And if you would like to get
your name in the credits or access to a
whole host of other rewards, you can go
sign up for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll include a link down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Thank you. Check it out. And if you'd
like to learn some poi dance basics to
go along with all of these tricks that
you're learning to help you convey
emotion, I'll go ahead and link to a
playlist of videos I have done on those
techniques up on screen as well as down
in the description. Thank you so much
for watching. Make sure to get out and
float yourselves today. And I'll see you
with a new video real soon. Take care
now.